[ominous music playing]
This is really
when the Guadalajara
cartel came together.
[church bells chiming]
It was a group of Mexican
drug traffickers saying,
OK, let's share our resources.
J. JESUS ESQUIVEL:
One of the pioneers
was Rafael Caro Quintero.
[ominous music continues]
He made what now is called
the Guadalajara Cartel using
the roads of Guadalajara
to send drugs to the United
States, especially marijuana.
[traffic humming]
[rooster crowing]
He came from a small
village in Sinaloa--
street thug, moved
up pretty quickly--
smart, though, for somebody
with a very limited education.
He saw an opportunity.
[music playing]
[speaking spanish]
[camera shutter clicking]
[music continues]
[speaking spanish]
[helicopter whirring]
They pretended to
be sophisticated,
and they were really just thugs.
They ruled by brutality--
by killing people who disagreed.
[ominous music continues]